we got the story here from breitbart
army reducing its numbers in face of
recruiting difficulties they see the
army this week admitted it was having
problems recruiting and announced an
unprecedented reduction in its number
size that would shrink the active duty
army to its smallest size since world
war ii wow that's great apparently uh uh
you've got retired army lieutenant
general thomas spewer
uh saying the army has not faced such
recruiting headwinds in the last 30
years i am unaware of a situation where
the army has cut its end strength in
response to a negative recruiting
outlook vladimir putin just drafted 134
500 people and the us is drawing down
his numbers being like nobody wants to
enlist
so uh uh thanks joe biden i guess well
and not just joe biden i mean we can
definitely attribute it to him even
though it started way before he was
president because what was it all the
way back in 1997 he was saying he wanted
to go to war with iraq he's the swamp
creature like the rest of him he pushed
for all this nonsense and this is what
happens when you go to war frivolously
it's not only a horrifically and
barbarically evil thing to do in and of
itself but of course you undermine your
credibility with the american people so
now when we're at a point in history
where global tensions really are
heightened we don't really have a
military in order to fight whatever war
might break out and other nations know
that but we got to be uh very serious
and specific here how long ago was the
two mom's army campaign yeah
last year wasn't it and now that clearly
did not work yeah
when you're recruiting three moms we
need a commercial with three months more
moms yeah more moms yeah just a whole
bunch of moms more is better
a bunch of faster funnier they didn't
put enough moms i don't think there was
enough moms in that situation it wasn't
loving enough it was only two you just
keep saying in circles first of all we
need more of them i had the most mothers
no but but in all seriousness
the army legitimately ran a campaign
that was all about diversity inclusivity
and equity die cult stuff and they did
that very famous uh two moms thing
clearly didn't work and it was animated
like a disney cartoon which was so
strange first of all who listens to a
cartoon right but also
i mean if you're trying to recruit
people for the military why are you
making this like sex the role of the
military
i was surprised that like the birds did
like the seagulls didn't fly to the ship
and start with them
i think it's fair to say legitimate
assessment the emma and her two moms
has uh has backfired on the army it that
they're it's it's an unprecedented
moment where they're drawing down their
end strength because they can't recruit
people to the lowest level since world
war ii when they drafted people
didn't they also kick people out of the
military for not getting vaccinated they
did and now they're removing the vaccine
mandates in new york let's think about
this like with the two months first of
all if anyone's going to dissuade you
from joining the army if it's going to
be either your parents it's going to be
your mother like odds are she like i
don't want my baby going over there and
fighting so catering to people with two
moms dude at least one of those moms is
going to go uh uh you know i'm not going
in my family my dad actually was like if
you have any creative bone in your body
do not join the military because they
will break it out of you you will lose
it forever because he got basically
forced to go vietnam he was either gonna
go drafted to the jungle so he signed up
for the navy and went and traveled the
world and then they've just you know
brow beaten told your scum clean the
deck piss
and uh this was my dad that told me that
he had actual experience really bad
didn't want to be there he didn't think
the war was valid it wasn't even a war
the military action was valid and i want
to i want to make a point right i want
to show this clip real quick just a
little bit not the whole thing
so there she is there you know her two
moms and
she said she was raised by two moms and
now i i take no issue with that
absolutely that's not what it's about
although i had a fairly typical
childhood
took ballet
played violin
i also marched for equality
i like to think i've been defending
freedom from an early age just like
here's here's the point i want to make
[ __ ] what
a military thing what is this military
yes military and you didn't and you
thought they would break your creativity
oh i should have joined the creative
army
they would have said hey express
yourself ian okay i'm sorry to interrupt
this is so disturbing who is their
target market you want young men that is
my point my point is you can get no no i
i'm not concerned about targeting just
young men uh if you want to get men and
women in the army i'm down for it
there's jobs that men and women can do
uh you want to talk about tucker carlson
and the pregnant flight suit thing
that's that's a little different but the
issue here is
the marketing campaign they made targets
no one yep nobody no no nobody who would
like yeah yeah no no no no no no no it's
targeting
their
this kind of virtue signaling is
extremely over the top the the target
market for this is woke
progressive millennials in gen z
but these people
are not the people who would ever
want to join the army ever yeah so it's
it's like trying it would be like
going to a fitness class expert level uh
uh um you know tai chi or martial arts
and trying to sell deep fried oreos and
and double scoop you know banana split
sundaes these people are going to be
like or i'll give you a better example
going to the olympics during training
season and being like here's a cart full
of deep fried ice cream well they give
them gatorade which has all sorts of
food coloring in it so they really don't
care at that point what are you doing
athletes you can't equate gatorade
it's similar
like what's the why are you selling food
coloring to your athletes okay okay
it's a little different i hear you guys
it's not great it's similar to fried
food like deep fried twinkies are
probably worse way worse and so the
point is that the army made a commercial
that probably insulted their target
demographic yes not because the the you
know people who join the army gonna see
this and be like oh i'm so offended at
two moms but more so they were like
do you think this is like this
represents us in any way well and this
goes back to the point we made earlier
right so when you look at who is who is
the democratic party speaking to right
now in their head but now i would say
that they actually did have a target
market for this it was exactly who they
this looks like it was for your your to
your point millennial gen gen z you know
rich progressive elitist and that is who
has become in their mind the democratic
approach for target market but that's
not really who your average democratic
voter is i mean if i'm out in indiana
right and i talk to a democrat they are
much more likely to be a new york
republican than they are a
aoc democrat but you said something i
think hits this as well wealthy the the
the people who believe these views the
progressive sect of this country are
well off up you know middle middle to
upper middle class upper class
suburbanite types yep they're the ones
who push this do you think that you you
are going to recruit this like 24 year
old progressive woman
no they're gonna be like um this ad is
so dumb because america is totally
racist
that those people who hate you are not
going to come work for you under
contract exactly you need the people who
are like america yeah yeah you want to
target it to kids that are bullied and
stuff like that i mean i'm not i'm not
advocating i'm not advocating for what
are you talking about i'm not advocating
for propaganda but if the military wants
to recruit people through propaganda you
want to target young men that feel
disillusioned and that they've been
victimized no no no no no you don't yeah
i mean that's what i would have done so
so here's why drafting doesn't work
you can't send people who've been
drafted to go do very serious things on
your behalf because they don't like you
yeah finding people who are bullied yeah
that's that's a terrible way to talk to
approach people i mean let's
want is people who are looking for
purpose and people who are driven you
want to approach them and say your
mission awaits there are people who need
you or go get it yeah
kind of i think that's part of it that's
what putin's doing with this military
that's why they've seen an uptick is
because he's got the ability to lead
with a purpose
versus the propaganda well yeah because
putin's able to tell us people if we
don't win this war mcdonald's will not
come back
like well we better go fight whatever
you say boss yeah like imagine i i kind
of feel like this is what the american
marketing department thinks they're like
millennials like disney
let's make an ad to recruit them like a
disney movie it's like no you understand
millennials liking disney means they're
not going to join right it's the
craziest thing there are these videos um
there's a i don't know the right word is
for it but there's a if you go to like
the cringe topia on reddit
there are people who who make these tick
tock videos where they talk in these
really weird ways where they like bounce
around yeah they're acting like disney
animation characters like when you're
watching a new pixar movie or whatever
they talk like this and they're like
flailing about for some reason yeah and
so you go you see that
this is they're they're they think is
that what we want in the army i i only
got to say that they're gonna give away
their position
that's not what i mean i just mean like
there are people who have become sort of
media mutated in their minds their
perception of reality yes it's not an
issue of what russia is doing it's an
issue of what the us is the the kids who
are growing up here have dejected and
twisted views of reality and they behave
in very strange and broken ways
it's it's just it's disparate
a cultural nonsense and the reason why i
think we're facing this recruiting
problem is because no one believes in
this country as evidenced by our own
politicians by the corporations by woke
activism in general when when when you
see someone like david hogg come out
this guy is famous for gun control
tweeting about why parents should be
allowed to have secret sexual
conversations with five-year-olds i'm
like
i kind of think you don't actually know
what you're talking about or care and
you're just saying whatever you think
the mob wants you to say which is the
most charitable response to someone
who's advocating for that right right
absolutely i mean honestly i think not
him but a lot of these people actually
are just pedo pedo adjacent groomers or
otherwise but my point is i don't want
to go off on it i don't want to derail
that far my point is
the united states has no cohesive
message
we don't tell our children this is our
mission so when they grow up they all
are just hey man it doesn't matter what
happens in this country i'll i'll
extract from it whatever i can the free
the message used to be freed american
freedom and then george bush invaded the
middle east and kept telling us because
they hate our freedom we got to keep
killing people and it just bastardized
and twisted the definition of the word
freedom and now no one understands what
freedom is anymore people are confused
it's true ian and it's funny because the
left sort of saw that early on and they
would scoff at anyone who used the term
freedom in a positive way because of
that and they would go oh you're talking
about fighting for our freedom they
thought it was the cringiest dumbest
thing ever but now they'll go we need to
protect our democracy against russia
this is the exact same thing yeah that's
not a democracy yeah it's a republic
yeah but but that
is democracy they don't even use
democracy in that
the phrasing of the way we look at
democracy they they use it as almost a
replacement for freedom it just means
good democracy
i think with respect to recruitment i
mean i
have friends who are combat veterans and
i remember having conversations with
them after afghanistan fell and i
mentioned this before but to us that was
a new story to them
they have friends who died there they'd
been shot at they'd really gone through
some horrific significant trauma
and then they just saw it all undone on
live television in front of them imagine
how horrible it is why would someone
want to enlist in this military at this
point in time given all of that there
used to be a time in this country when
the higher-ups in our government who
would send young men to fight in wars
respected them and then we got into a
period where they more or less were
different to them and now we're at a
point in time where the people who send
these young men to fighting wars or
expect them to fight wars actively hate
them and everything they stand for and
everything they believe in and they're
not idiots they know that who who's
going to fight a war for joe biden
he's going to fight a war for nancy
pelosi not only do the young people not
want to fight my dad literally had to
was involved in the vietnam conflict and
told me to my face do not join the
military yeah but that was he drafted or
did he left he
uh he was able to avoid the draft
because he enlisted ahead of time they
were calling the numbers he's like i'm
not going to the jungle no way i'm
joining the i'm joined the navy so he
enlisted an effort to try the navy it's
like get a specific mo or something to
get just to not get drafted into the
into the jungle like his cousin got shot
down in a helicopter and died yeah
oh i'm sorry i mean
so it wasn't only that i saw how dumb it
was and she chose it was my father
actively told me not to do it so you not
only do people not believe in it their
parents are telling them don't do it
yeah my so my dad was in high school i
just think just to to add to this
and this is so foreign to us but
he told me that like every single
morning on the announcements they would
listen to the radio to know which
students or teachers got drafted and one
of his teachers who was young and had
just started teaching there ended up
getting drafted into the war and i'm
pretty sure he died dude you got to
study like tunnel rats they would send
these little guys down underground to
crawl through these tunnels like
sometimes they would cave in and they'd
suffocate sometimes there'd be a guy
three feet in front of him in the dark
with a gun pointed at their face
then they'd have to go set bombs under
in these tunnels all the vietnamese this
is like this is the war you want to
avoid this is like
and think back to like 20 years earlier
you had the world war ii veterans right
and i remember back when i was in school
like you'd go to the am vets and you'd
see that that you know the group of the
remaining world war ii vets and that was
the people that they'd have come talk to
the school up in northern new york and
like you'd see like them talk about
defending american freedom helping
defend interest over abroad and like
fighting back the nazis and that was
something you could get on board with i
think like your average person's like
yeah like nazis nazi equal bad whereas
you look to vietnam and it's like we're
gonna go to a jungle for 20 years and do
what this shell for 20 years this civil
war that's coming is going to be
fascists versus pedos the left is going
to scream everybody they're going to
tell everyone the fascists must be
stopped and everyone the right's going
to be like the pedos must be stopped
those are those are the you know have
you guys seen uh operation okay groomer
that's been going around no no so
trending though yeah yeah because
basically the meme is
anybody supporting the protests you know
they don't say gay protest stuff they're
groomers so they say okay groomer and
it's really triggering a lot of these
people on the left but i bring this up
not to derail the conversation in this
direction but to point out
there used to be an american message
the uh the red scare the soviets the
expansion
so everyone in america was kind of
unified
you could you could you could get people
to enlist who believed in it and you
could draft people as much as many
people didn't want to be drafted
nowadays the u.s is split not just into
there's disparate factions all over the
place i mean progressives wouldn't fight
for democrats but they'll take what they
can get in terms of politics like if an
actual fight broke out anti-fun
democrats would not be getting along
so when it comes to going to someone and
saying what's your purpose and what's
your mission
you know people in the u.s are not going
to say i oppose russia they're going to
say the critical race theory die cult
left is destroying the planet
that's internal yeah the left is going
to say the fascists they support putin
internal
that's true no i mean that's a very good
point we talked about this before i
think it was actually a conversation
with jack pasobic
and it might have been a point ian
brought up but basically how we live in
a system where because power changes
hands so often you can't really achieve
anything but historically that wasn't
really the case because even though the
two parties had different ideas they
were similar enough that we could work
towards a common goal though we might
have different approaches or have a
slightly different vision it was still
possible to like continue along a
specific path for a set amount of time
even with a change in leadership but now
it's like a complete regime change in
some sense when a new person gets
elected at least with respect to the lip
surf as they pay the public and what
they tell people we want to do so
yeah you're right if you ask most people
what the most serious threat is
the right's going to point to the left
and the left's going to point to the
right the who cares about foreign
adversaries at this point unfortunately
though you might if you're paying
attention well there will be some
conversation the right will say china
the left will say russia but for the
most part i'd be willing to bet if you
went to someone unprompted like a
political leftist and you'd say what is
the what is the existential threat this
country faces today they're going to say
the rise of fascism
you ask someone on the right they're
going to say the critical race theorist
the cult the right may also actually say
china to be honest which is fascist
that's where it starts to con what is
that it's something else
it's fashion yeah the ccp is the most
fascist country on earth i mean maybe
the united
is pretty all the businesses run through
that government it's excessive
like just to do internet you have to go
through china telecom yeah yeah i don't
think the united states is fascist
it's got elements of with the federal
reserve yeah but bro like national
fascism was something specific that's
why i i just i grew tired of using these
words even the communism it's because
those are 100 years old 100 year old
terms for specific things and ideologies
that existed during the you know
post-industrial revolution we're dealing
with something unique and and worse in a
lot of ways yeah it's it's it's
it's the matrix there's got to be a
different word for it so yeah i still i
understand it doesn't apply perfectly in
all instances i still tend to use the
word communism just because the sort of
you know
egalitarian dialectical materialism
undergirding communism is what
undergirds this stuff but fascism is is
trickier because
most people who are called fascists
don't identify as fascists there are
still people on the world stage who will
identify as communists so like the ccp
call themselves communist i mean who
calls themselves
it is socially acceptable among the left
to throw up the red salute yeah
it that's just insane to me it's it's
mind-blowingly insane to me i view the
red salute and the roman salute
similarly yeah i mean truth be told
soviets killed
uh communists i should say soviets but
killed way more people but they're both
psychotic ideologies that represent i
mean guevara gets like canonized on the
constant from leftist homophobe right he
was super anti-gay and all that and
racist like murder gay people in cuba
yeah
he did he was racist
very very racist guy that seems like
problematic isn't that the way we use
probably like we know that the left
doesn't care at all about human life but
if we can convince them that the guy's
racist like it's like a worse person
yeah yeah i mean truth be told if you
were like he killed people they'd be
like everybody kills people in war that
happens but he killed gay people
and they're like hold on
oh five inconvenient truths about shay
guevara from fox news how's this
inconvenient he's a murderous dick
i know i was just gonna say that dude
even fox news going oh how inconvenient
that shay guevara did it's like it's not
like he's george washington you're going
that's unfortunate five sad truths about
washington in 1962 guevara said he
killed people without regard to guilt or
innocence this guy's crazy psycho but he
was beautiful so they loved him he's
cute but they're a little bit entranced
by the way things look have you seen the
thing recently they're standing young uh
young stalin
there's look up young stalin
so i'm pretty sure that picture of young
stalin i've seen this and i'm pretty
sure it's it's not actually him i need
to double check before i understand it
was like
it's debunked and it was uh because
maybe a propaganda to make him look like
he looked better that's been blowing up
all over social media i saw on twitter
to have like thousands of reasons let's
do operation photoshopped fat stalin and
just make like really unattractive we
have to do that with putin you want to
win the war that's how you do it
stalin where he was like waving at that
water body of water and they erased the
guy yeah just take that picture and just
make sure no no
you need young stalin to be a loser
so that they stop posting this young
joseph stalin he looks like uh
was it gavrilo princep the guy that
started world war one that murdered that
uh he looks like that guy he reminded me
of um
the hell's the guy from uh the young
turks
thank you
no no no no no no no no
no
sasha
the fake young turks not the real ones
not the murderers that's not the real
yeah i get confused
the ones who were inspired by those who
committed genocide not the ones who
actually did it yes thank you for the
ones who initially denied the genocide
not the perpetrators of it or the ones
who have been uh repeatedly begged to
change their name to stop using the name
of a group that carried a genocide and
whoever refused yeah the armenian
genocide could you imagine if someone
started a news organization called the
hitler hitler youth right
also and also like the head of that
organization for a very long time like
actively denied the holocaust but but
then later apologized big deal but then
later apologized but still continued to
call his organization the hitler youth
are you really sorry thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you